la veille de l'audience au fond il a été
incarcéré dans le cadre de la purge
terre dogan et donc c'est un nouveau
président et une nouvelle composition de
chambre qui au pied levé a repris le
dossier sans le connaître et au cours
d'une audience qui a duré 15 minutes a
prononcé cette semaine folle que vous
venez de rappeler et 20 ans qui a été
réduite à ces deux ans et huit mois
alors c'est ce que c'était un verdict
exceptionnel ou c ou c ça ne nous a pas
étonné alors ça nous a étonné puisque
l'avocate sûrs que nous a dit ça va être
qualifié de consommation personnelle ne
vous inquiétez pas c'est un produit qui
n'a aucune valeur commerciale
il était interdit depuis très peu de
temps turquie donc je ne suis pas
inquiète
on aura une peine pour la consommation
simple et comme il est étrange et ça
sera deux ans avec bras panon oui mais
oui mais sauf qu'il fait partie mais
c'est à dire qu'il est renvoyé
immédiatement en france exactement doit
alors qu'il a sa condamnation mais il
reste pas en prison et rentre c'est pas
du tout c'est passé c'est ce qu'ils nous
ont expliqué les avocats de chips qui
restera en turquie exactement
alors très vite en prison ses conditions
de détention se dégrader et devenir
terrible dans une première mission dans
une première prison il va être même
victime d'une tentative de meurtre
oui alors ça a été qualifiée comme ça
mais en réalité c'est plus des actes de
torture c'est à dire que y'a un de ses
codétenus il
il s est terrible dans les lettres qu'il
a écrit à ses proches
il explique il a essayé de cacher sa
religion qu'il a essayé de se protéger
au maximum
il explique que certains de ses co
détenus avec des croix gammées sous leur
matelas qu'ils doivent relever en fait
tous les soirs donc quand il sortait de
la cellule ils passaient devant ce
couloir de matelas les croix gammées
on allait l'être notamment et est donc
cette agression
c'est un de ses codétenus qui le noise
ou les évoque forcément la communauté
juive et à istanbul c'est quand même des
prisons qui sont internationale
contrairement à la prison où il est
actuellement
et donc il a décidé en pleine nuit de
faire bouillir de l'eau dans les
marmites et il lui a jeté sur le corps
pendant qu'ils dorment et en fait
fabien a été transféré
à l'hôpital bien évidemment et ensuite
il sera changé de prison quelques
semaines après et son agresseur a bien
évidemment été enfin je dis bien
évidemment mais il aurait pu ne pas
l'être en turquie mais il a été condamné
il a ensuite été déplacé il est
désormais détenu à 800 km au nord-est
d'istanbul dans une prison difficile
d'accès où il partage sa cellule avec
huit autres co détenus
c'est ça comment est-ce que vous avez
des nouvelles parce que on a des lettres
un de fabien puis qu'un bateau quatre
ans il vit un enfer il parfois et il
change avec ses proches par courrier
notamment avec avec son meilleur ami
david david david et sophie présidente
du comité de soutien de fabien boulay
sophie est ce que vous avez eu des
nouvelles dernièrement de fabien non non
genève
j'ai des nouvelles uniquement via son
frère xavier qui peut lui parler
chaque mardi mais les nouvelles qu'il a
sont hélas très mauvaise
il prend beaucoup de médicaments pour
passer la douleur morale
il ne veut ne veut pas terminer la
quatrième année qui sera en septembre
dans cette prison ils pensent ils à des
pensées suicidaires et ses jours sont
vraiment content et il est en danger de
mort